every Thursday we highlight stories
affecting consumers we've partnered with
kaiser Health News and NPR on their bill
of the month series which uncover
shocking medical bills this morning
we're looking at how emergency room fees
are fueling rising healthcare costs
between 2009 and 2016 er charges nearly
doubled they are rising at four times
the rate of overall health care spending
according to the health care cost
Institute one Colorado man told us he
got hit with a huge medical bill after
celebrating a little bit too hard at his
bachelor party
the following day had a pretty bad
hangover by evening Cameron Fisher was
so nauseous his fiancee Kaitlyn decided
they should skip their own rehearsal
dinner he just couldn't hold anything
down I wanted to take him into the
hospital just to make sure that he was
okay and ready for our wedding at a
free-standing er outside Denver a blood
test confirmed Cameron was dehydrated it
was two liters of saline it took about
30 to 45 minutes to go through all of it
the groom felt great on their wedding
day but Cameron stomach was back in
knots a few weeks later when the
hospital bill arrived that was the price
for the actual room the total more than
$12,000 including a seven thousand six
hundred and forty-four dollar facility
fee $700 for two bags of saline and
charges for tests he says he didn't even
know were ordered what they told me was
that by signing the consent form
whenever I checked in that authorized
them to run any and all tests north
suburban Medical Center said in a
statement when patients present to our
emergency room board-certified
physicians examine and address their
medical needs the amount patients pay
out-of-pocket for their emergency room
care is based upon their insurance
Camryn's insurance company negotiated
the bill down to roughly forty seven
hundred dollars and paid nearly $2,100
he owes the rest my wife and I just
recently found out that we're pregnant
so that's money that would be going to
making sure our child is actually cared
for dr. Elizabeth Rosenthal
editor-in-chief of kaiser Health News
joins us at the table doctor good
morning so your website
reported that the two bags of saline
solution were available at Walmart for
1099 instead of $700 and if you've got
Walmart there isn't a multi-thousand
dollar facility fee so I mean this was
double the cost of his actual wedding
what do people need to know gosh well
you have to know first of all you play
defensive emergency rooms aren't gonna
be the mark-up is gonna be 30 40 50
times what you would be available on the
outside so I always tell people and you
know poor guy
think twice before you use an emergency
room do I really really really really
need to go there yes we've had people
who come in our bill of the month series
for a splinter and you know eight
thousand dollars later they're like damn
I could have gone they finally said that
the nearby urgent care centers were all
closed right so what option do they have
well that's part of the point you
unfortunately you have to play kind of
defensive medicine as a patient you have
to know when did the urgent care centers
close around my my my locale so I always
tell people if you think you might need
to go go before before they go now
because ER is gonna be much more
expensive the other thing is you can
have a primary care doctor this kind of
thing if you had a doctor you had a
relationship with who had after-hours
call you could say hey I had this you
know I have a really bad hangover I'm
getting married tomorrow
he could have prescribed some medicine
to calm down the nausea and then Cameron
could have probably drunk water that
pedialite is good young people's homes
they appear right and they don't have
babies and I was wondering that is that
work you can use Pedialyte or I worked
as an ER doctor and we experienced this
um you can give people dilute kind of
semi warm ginger ale works nicely
anything but what about the blood tests
also what you said about the doctor he
or she I think it's always good to have
a good relationship with your doctor
maybe you have a number where you can
reach him or her after hours right but
the other part of the story that stuck
out to me stood out to me was about the
blood test right that he that he was
charged for blood test that he didn't
even order right now so the other thing
you can do defensively is when you go to
an emergency room and the the doctor or
the nurse says we're just going to order
some Bloods you can say why what are
they for I mean this kid
knew a kid this young man knew exactly
what was wrong
so all that blood stuff wasn't probably
necessary and ER doctors frequently
they're not bad people but they're kind
of ordering from a checklist you know
kid who's nauseous check check check
check check dr. Elizabeth Rosenthal
thank you very much we appreciate